bonjour marie pierre martin merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur
arte france
le projet de référendum d'initiative
partagée porté sur le site l'accès à un
service public hospitalier de qualité ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire que
l'hôpital public en france n'est pas de
qualité pourtant on a souvent entendu
par le passé que le système français
était l'un des meilleurs si ce n'est le
meilleur au monde
ben c'était c'était il ya très longtemps
ça je pense que depuis depuis 10e 18
mois avec la crise qu vide on se rend
bien compte que l'hôpital il n'est pas
du tout en mesure de prendre en charge
les français correctement on n'est pas
en mesure de faire des soins de qualité
et avec le collectif interrogeant ça
faisait déjà deux ans qu ont été
mobilisés même deux ans et demi
maintenant ça fait ça fait un an et demi
qu'on a une crise sanitaire qui secoue
l'hôpital où on tient les moeurs car on
peut ou on demande plus de moyens à tort
et à travers en vain et on avait ce
projet qui était un projet qu'ils
pouvaient faire vraiment changer les
choses et qui vient d'être refusée donc
c'est très dommage vous venez d'évoquer
la crise sanitaire elle a généré
beaucoup de départs d'infirmiers 7500
postes vacants en juin 2020 34000 en
septembre 2020 selon les mots de tirer
amoureux le porte parole du snpl le
manque d'attractivité de l'hôpital
public il est dû uniquement au co vide
ou bien il est plus structurel il est
dieu et les dieux à plein de choses
aujourd'hui comment voulez aller faire
un métier où vous allez forcément devoir
remettre en cause vos valeurs et vos
valeurs professionnelles parce que vous
n'avez pas les moyens de le faire comme
vous voulez l'attractivité s'est pas
uniquement le salaire c'est aussi être
en mesure de prendre en soins aux
patients correctement ne pas être dans
des politiques de de rentabilité en
permanence ce qui est actuellement c'est
le cas de pas avoir l'impression de
torturer nos patients parce que c'est ça
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que quand
on est à l'hôpital on a l'impression de
de torturer nos patients de prendre des
nos patients en charge de les prendre en
charge de manière dégradé et ça c'est
inadmissible en fait pour revenir sur
le projet de référendum retoquée par par
les sages ces derniers ont parlé de
l'article 7 ans dans ce paragraphe je
cite subordonne à l'avis conforme de la
conférence nationale de santé sur
l'exercice du pouvoir réglementaire du
premier ministre est donc contraire à la
constitution un texte rejeté pour une
raison technique un seul article sur 11
non conformes ça vous évoque quoi bein
c'est très dommage c'est très dommage
parce que on sait qu'ils peuvent faire
des des refus partiel est actuellement
ce n'est pas le cas ils ont refusé
complètement le texte c'est dommage à
plusieurs niveaux c'est dommage pour
l'hôpital qui a vraiment besoin d'une
réforme profonde vu l'état de l'hôpital
actuel et vu l'état des soins en france
et c'est dommage pour nos patients parce
qu'au final ce qu'ils vont en pâtir
c'est seynod patience et vous cessez vos
familles et vos amis
c'est nous aussi c'est nous tous qui
allons en pâtir et c'est ça en fait le
plus dommage là dedans alors après ce
rejet
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant est ce
qu'il ya un recours possible au niveau
de la voie juridique
ou bien est-ce que l'unique façon de
vous faire entendre c'est la rue on va
voir on va se regrouper entre nous on va
continuer avec cette association à notre
hôpital c'est vous qui a été créé pour
ce projet là et on va trouver des
solutions toutes façons ne s'arrêtera
pas on n'arrêtera pas aujourd'hui le
combat pour l'hôpital public parce que
c'est trop important à c'est trop grave
concrètement qu'est-ce qui manque
justement l'hôpital public
vis-à-vis par exemple des cliniques
privées je ne peux pas comparer avec les
cliniques privées ces deux modes de
financement très différents et en fait
le soin en france est dégradée par tous
c'est ça qui est dommage c'est que alex
temps à l'hôpital qu'en médecine de
ville que tout ça ça suit pas et
aujourd'hui on a besoin de réinjecter
des moyens dans l'hôpital on a besoin de
réinjecter des moyens dedans parce que
la santé c'est quelque chose c'est un
bien précieux et aujourd'hui ce bien il
est mis à mal
merci marie pierre martin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
ce message fort qui vous fait passer
vous êtes infirmière au service urgences
de l'hôpital necker à paris et vous êtes
membre également du collectif inter
urgence